Kim Kardashian just got trolled by
Taylor Swift fans hard these are things
that don't break out in a full-body
sweat on Wednesday the 39 year old
reality star shared this pic with her
hubby Kanye and their kids together at
home asking fans in the caption quote
what is everyone doing to keep your kids
entertained as a family we are social
distancing but need some fun ideas of
what to do any suggestions would help
yeah well ask you for suggestions really
set off Taylor's loyal fans who aren't
too happy with Kim after the full video
of that infamous 2016 phone call between
Taylor and Kanye was leaked last week
one user wrote try illegally recording
phone calls and editing them don't be
another accommodated quote have a Taylor
Swift marathon while several swifty
suggested Kim watched Taylor's Netflix
documentary miss Americana I'm highly
aware of the fact that that is not
normal
oh but it didn't stop there guys another
chimed in writing maybe discuss the
consequences of lying and then there was
this mic drop quote you can spend time
editing videos to frame people you're
gonna have a lot of fun trust me
awkward right some fans are even
claiming that Kim has since deleted
their comments of course this all comes
after a tense back-and-forth between
Taylor and Kim over the past week after
the footage leaked Taylor hit up her
insta story to claim that when Kim first
released clips from the illegally
recorded call it had been edited and
manipulated to paint her as a liar lots
of fans claimed the full audio
leak-proof Taylor was right in her
ongoing drama with Kim and Kanye
naturally Kim took to Twitter to defend
herself quote to be clear the only issue
I ever had around the situation was that
Taylor lied through her publicist who
stated that Kanye never called to ask
for permission nobody ever denied the
word was used without her permission I
feel like me and Taylor might steal that
Wow I made that
the light was never about the word it
was always whether there was a call or
not and the tone of the conversation the
camera crew filmed him speaking to
Taylor and got their whole conversation
I think she got freaked out by the
reaction and all of a sudden she flips
Kim also defended Kanye's choice to film
the call saying that the footage never
would have been made public had Taylor
not live and forced Kim to defend him
I'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face and if you thought it ended
there think again people Kim also shot
down the claims that she had edited the
footage to make Taylor look bad saying
she only posted a few clips to her
snapchat adding that the new footage
doesn't change the narrative I would
very much like to be excluded from this
narrative
[Music]